bien mes chers collègues
nous nous installons
monsieur le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues nous retrouvons ce matin après
une courte nuit
Gabriel Attal ministre délégué chargé
des comptes publics sur le projet de loi
de finances rectificative pour 2022 qui
a été présenté hier en conseil des
ministres
ce PLF ne remet pas en cause le cadrage
macroéconomique retenu en septembre
dernier puisque les prévisions de
croissance à 2,7% pour 2022 et
d'inflation à 5,3% sont inchangés le
déficit public serait très d'argent
légèrement revu à la baisse à 4,9% du
PIB au lieu de 5%. et la dette resterait
estimée à 111,5% du PIB en fin d'année
pour autant se plaire comporte des
mesures nouvelles en dépense notamment
pour faire face à la hausse des prix de
l'énergie financés par des recettes plus
élevées qu'attendues et des annulations
de crédit j'ai 700 plus attendre la
parole au ministre pour nous exposer le
détail de ces mouvements on refaites et
en dépense et je vous rappelle mes chers
collègues que notre audition est
retransmise sur le site internet du
Sénat monsieur ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs après vous avoir quitté
notamment sur la loi de programmation
des finances publiques nous nous
retrouvons ce matin pour le deuxième
projet de loi de finances rectificatif
pour l'année 2022 après nous être
projeté dans les 5 années à venir nous
retournons dans le présent le présent
immédiat puisqu'il s'agit du PLFR
classique de fin de gestion pour l'année
2022 c'est un texte donc qui est
classique mais au-delà de sa dimension
technique il traduit des choix qui n'ont
pas variés pour après presque parler
d'une logique de complément ou de
rallonge par rapport au PLFR adopté
précédemment cet été puisqu'il s'agit
toujours d'aider notre pays à faire face
à l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie
dans la continuité du paquet pouvoir
d'achat présenté en juillet et largement
enrichi par le travail parlementaire
vous vous en souvenez le premier PLFR a
constituer un effort de soutien
absolument majeur puisqu'il recouvrait
44 milliards d'euros de crédit
supplémentaire dont 20 milliards d'euros
consacrés à la protection du pouvoir
d'achat le texte que nous vous
présentons aujourd'hui et certes plus
modeste dans ses ambitions budgétaires
mais il permet néanmoins d'assurer le
financement de mesures qui vont protéger
le quotidien des français tout en
procédant à un certain nombre
d'ajustements dans une logique très
classique de fin de gestion comme le PLF
de juillet ce texte traduit d'abord une
volonté de soutenir et de protéger dans
un contexte où l'inflation reste à des
niveaux élevés et où la puissance
publique a le devoir de continuer à
répondre au présent pour ma part il me
semble donc une large majorité peut-être
rassemblée derrière cet objectif vous le
savez notre principal défi c'est d'aider
l'économie française à résister face à
la flambée des prix de l'énergie la
première ministre l'a rappelé lors de sa
conférence de presse jeudi dernier les
prix de marché du gaz et de
l'électricité seront l'année prochaine
plus de 10 fois supérieur à ceux de 2020
c'est un choc majeur auquel nous faisons
ça face il s'agit donc d'aider
la croissance réalisée ne dépend pas
d'une controverse entre expert ou entre
politique mais de la confiance que nous
serons capables de créer et des réformes
que nous sont capables de conduire au
service de l'activité économique dans
notre pays je crois que le texte qui
vous est présenté aujourd'hui contribue
à créer je l'espère de la confiance
parce qu'il montre que l'État continue à
lutter sans relâche contre l'inflation
et ses effets dans la continuité de la
loi de finances rectificative adopter
cet été pour renforcer le soutien au
ménage face à la hausse des factures ce
PLFR mais en oeuvre l'annonce de la
première ministre concernant le
versement d'un chèque énergie
exceptionnel le 16 septembre dernier le
gouvernement a en effet annoncé l'octroi
d'un chèque énergie exceptionnel à 12
millions de ménages ce chèque énergie
sera de 200 euros pour les ménages déjà
bénéficiaires du chèque énergie
classique et de 100 euros pour les
ménages des 3e et 4e des cils c'est pour
faire face à l'augmentation des prix de
l'électricité et du gaz de 15% qui aura
lieu en début d'année j'en profite pour
rappeler que la LFR un a prévu un budget
de 230 millions d'euros pour aider les
ménages se chauffant au fioul c'est très
attendu par nos concitoyens qui se
chauffent au fioul cette aide dont le
contenu a été défini en lien avec les
groupes politiques se traduit par
l'attribut l'attribution d'un chèque
énergie spécifique au fioul pour les 5
premiers des cils ce chèque est de 200
euros pour les ménages déjà
bénéficiaires du chèque énergie et de
100 euros pour les ménages des 3e à 5e
des cils il pourra être versé à partir
du 8 novembre vous le savez la première
ministre a également annoncé une
prolongation jusqu'à la mi-novembre de
la ristourne de 30 centimes par litre
pour le carburant pour tenir compte du
blocage des raffineries et des
difficultés d'approvisionnement non
pattis encore nos compatriotes les
médias en parlent moins mais dans un
certain nombre de régions notamment en
Île-de-France il reste de très grandes
difficultés pour nos concitoyens pour
faire le plein d'essence nous
prolongeons donc la ristourne carburant
de 15 jours elle devait s'arrêter mardi
prochain cette prolongation représente
un coup pour nos finances publiques de
440 millions d'euros
entre le 15 novembre et le 31 décembre
elle sera réduite à 10 centimes par
litre comme nous l'avions annoncé pour
autant 2023 ne sera pas un synonyme d'un
arrêt brutal du soutien apporté à nos
automobilistes la réalité c'est que nous
devons continuer à soutenir ce que l'on
a appelé désormais un peu communément
les gros rouleurs moi je parle plus
volontiers de gros bosseurs c'est à dire
les Français qui travaillent qui
travaillent dur qui ont besoin leur
voiture pour aller travailler qui
peuvent pas faire autrement qui se
prennent de plein fouet la hausse des
prix du carburant et aller travailler ne
doit jamais coûter plus cher que ne pas
aller travailler et donc le président de
la République l'a dit la semaine
dernière un dispositif ciblé sur ces
travailleurs sera mis en place avec des
modalités qui vont être définies
précisément dans les prochaines semaines
mais qui devraient être assez proche de
ce que nous avions envisagé en juillet
avec l'indemnité carburant travailleur
dont nous avions donné des informations
sur les contours il s'agit en effet
d'agir de manière plus ciblée en
concentrant l'argent public sur celles
et ceux qui en ont le plus besoin pour
dire les choses simplement le combien ça
coûte que je défends si souvent n'a
jamais voulu dire que nous allions
laisser les Français à la merci de
l'inflation simplement dans un contexte
où la France empreinte désormais à des
taux compris entre 2,5 et 3 % il serait
déraisonnable de déverser l'argent
public sans distinguer entre les
situations individuelles et niveau de
revenus je rappelle par ailleurs que le
Parlement adopté cet été aussi un
doublement du plafond du chèque
carburant défiscalisé que peuvent verser
les entreprises à destination de leurs
salariés qui ont besoin de leur voiture
pour aller travailler nous souhaitons
évidemment que les entreprises qui le
peuvent s'en saisissent à compter de
début 2023 vous le voyez ce PLFR est
donc un texte dont les mesures
contribueront à soutenir nos
compatriotes dans leur quotidien c'est
aussi un texte de soutien aux opérateurs
de l'État je pense notamment aux
universités aux établissements de
recherche et aux CROUS afin de les aider
à faire face à la hausse des prix de
l'énergie nous avons donc prévu un fond
de 275 millions d'euros immédiatement
des blocables pour bénéfice des
comparateur du ministère de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche nous savons avec ma collègue
Sylvie retaillod que certaines
universités sont tentées de privilégier
l'enseignement à distance cet hiver pour
limiter leur facture de chauffage et
d'éclairage pour notre part nous
préférons des amphis remplis et éclairés
même si cela doit mobiliser de l'argent
public dans la même logique ce PLF
prévoit des ouvertures de crédit pour
les frais de carburant exceptionnel du
ministère des armées pour les opérations
extérieures besoin de carburant
opérationnel évident
des coûts du carburant il faut soutenir
nos armées pour qu'elles puissent
continuer à s'approvisionner une
enveloppe de 200 millions d'euros et
donc prévu pour cela ce sont donc 2
milliards 500 millions d'euros qui sont
mis sur la table pour aider les Français
et certains opérateurs de l'État à faire
face aux chocs énergétiques il ne s'agit
pas de parer uniquement à l'urgence il
s'agit aussi au travers de ce texte de
procéder à un certain nombre
d'ajustements de fin de gestion avec le
souci permanent de tenir les comptes
publics
au global les ouvertures de crédit
auxquels nous procédons pour assurer de
nouvelles dépenses sont de l'ordre de 5
milliards d'euros ces ouvertures sont
compensées par des annulations de crédit
d'un montant identique
autrement dit il y a les dépenses
exceptionnelles liées à l'inflation pour
soutenir le pouvoir d'achat des Français
et les opérateurs de l'autre côté il y a
des ouvertures de crédit qui ne sont pas
immédiatement liées à ces dépenses
exceptionnelles ces autres ouvertures de
crédit sont intégralement compensées par
des annulations de crédit à du
concurrence c'est donc un texte
d'équilibre budgétaire hors dépenses
exceptionnelles liées à la crise de
l'énergie la principale ouverture de
crédit à hauteur de 2 milliards d'euros
permet de soutenir la trésorerie de
France compétences conséquence de la
poursuite de l'envol du nombre de
contrats d'apprentissage dans notre pays
ce qui est évidemment une bonne nouvelle
pour les jeunes en apprentissage une
bonne nouvelle pour les entreprises et
une bonne nouvelle pour l'économie
française d'une manière générale je
rappelle que la loi de finance
rectificative cet été avait déjà ouvert
un milliard 800 millions d'euros de
crédit pour France compétences et près
de 750 millions d'euros pour les primes
d'apprentissage on voit bien qu'il y a
un besoin de rallonge de trésorerie ce
qui dit d'une part qu'il y a un succès
dans la politique de l'apprentissage
mais de l'autre que nous devons
évidemment continuer à rechercher des
économistes structurelles chez France
compétences et ça sera notamment un gros
débat qu'on aura dans le PLF puisque des
mesures ont été adoptées dans le cadre
du 49-3 des amendements ont été retenus
par le gouvernement pour réaliser des
économies supplémentaires chez France
compétences autre ouverture
significative un milliard 100 millions
d'euros sont ouverts pour la mission
défense pour financer le soutien
militaire que nous apportons à l'Ukraine
nous ouvrons également des crédits à
hauteur de 450 millions d'euros pour
prolonger le financement des mesures
d'indemnisation des crises agricoles
survenu cette année en contrepartie je
le disais nous procédons à des
annulations de crédit de montant
équivalents qui ont pour effet de
couvrir intégralement les ouvertures que
je viens de présenter j'imagine que nous
aurons l'occasion d'y revenir durant
cette audition
je vous disais que notre premier
objectif est d'aider l'économie
française a absorber le choc le deuxième
est de tenir nos comptes conformément
aux engagements que nous avons pris
vis-à-vis de nos partenaires européens
et vis-à-vis des Français et donc je le
disais alors dépense exceptionnelle lié
à la crise de l'énergie nous vous
présentons un texte sans ouverture net
et 5 milliards d'euros à nouveau sont
gagés compensés par des annulations
preuve de cette ligne il nous pousse à
chercher continuellement à tenir nos
comptes le sol de budgétaire étant
légère très légère amélioration et
devrait s'établir à 4,9% pour l'année
2022 soit 01 point de mieux que la
prévision réalisée pour la dernière loi
de finances rectificative cette
amélioration s'explique par une
réévaluation des recettes plus élevées
que les dépenses nouvelles permissent
par ce projet de loi ces nouvelles ces
recettes supplémentaires par rapport aux
prévisions sont notamment le fruit de
l'impôt sur le revenu et de l'impôt sur
les sociétés ce qui est aussi un signe
supplémentaire que l'économie française
résiste c'est évidemment une bonne
nouvelle dont je le sais nous nous
félicitons et nous nous réjouissons
collectivement notre économie résiste il
y a évidemment des aléas évidemment des
turbulences mais nous avons un acquis de
croissance à 2,5% alors que cet objectif
était remis en question et parfois mis
en doute par certains prévisionnistes il
y a encore quelques mois et nous avons
des entreprises qui continuent à
investir en témoigne les chiffres les
derniers chiffres de l'Insee avec une
poursuite notable de la progression de
l'investissement dans notre pays au
dernier trimestre
il ne s'agit pas de s'adresser des
satisfaits mais simplement de constater
que notre pays malgré les aléas ne cette
pas un pouce de terrain au laisser aller
budgétaires cette trajectoire de sérieux
qui je le redis n'a rien à voir avec
l'austérité nous la tiendrons en 2023 et
pour les années suivantes afin d'assurer
la stabilisation de la dette et le
retour du déficit sous la barre des 3%
avant la fin du quinquennat oui je crois
que nous pouvons nous rassembler
derrière cet objectif de protection de
compatriotes comme nous pouvons nous
rassembler derrière celui de la tenue de
nos comptes je vous remercie me tient
désormais à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions
merci monsieur le ministre sans plus
attendre je vais donner la parole
rapporteur général oui merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le ministre
de cette présentation
je vais aborder tout de suite
[Musique]
cette
ce projet de la finance rectificative à
travers quatre questions une première
sur la question des la prévision de
croissance du PIB à deux sets
qui donc reste inchangé par rapport à
celle indiqué dans le PLF pour 2023 le
Haut Conseil d'ailleurs la juge crédible
au regard des informations dont il
dispose mais depuis les laboration de
cet avis l'INSEE a publié les comptes
nationaux du 3e trimestre de cette année
qui qui note un ralentissement de
l'activité et l'Insee
prévoit également que l'activité ne
devrait pas progresser au quatrième
trimestre et à cet égard est-ce que la
croissance du PIB en 2022 serait de et
qu'elle serait de 200 que non de deux
sets quelles sont par rapport à cette
remarque et assez prévisions vos
observations et en vous des conséquences
concrètes sur le budget deuxième
question elle concerne les autorisations
d'emploi qu'à croient d'ailleurs ce
périphérent pour plus de 1100
équivalents en plein travaillé
pour l'État et ses opérateurs au titre
de 2022 ma question est-ce que vous
comptez déposer un amendement sur le PLF
pour accroître en conséquence les
plafonds d'emploi de 2023 ou alors cette
augmentation n'est-elle qu'une
anticipation par rapport aux
augmentations que vous avez déjà prévues
pour 2023 et vous nous l'avez dit au
nombre de 20000 et PPT avec des effets
de périmètre puisqu'il y aura également
des réorganisations des redéploiements
troisième question
ça devient un irritant pour la
commission des finances c'est le fameux
sujet de France compétences qui est un
espèce de puissant fondre un canard sans
tête où on met régulièrement des sommes
important je n'ose pas les qualifier
autrement mais en tous les cas qui
paraissent déraisonnable par rapport à
ce qui me paraît être une imprévision de
la part du gouvernement là c'est encore
2 milliards d'euros après les 2
milliards d'euros déjà de cet été
heureusement j'espère qu'il y aura pas
une un nouveau PLFR avant la fin de
l'année parce qu'on remettrait 2
milliards il y a un espèce d'abonnement
comment expliquer vous ces besoins
comment ne pas avoir mieux intégré dans
vos prévisions de l'été puisqu'on était
comme au mois de juillet ne jamais on
n'est jamais que début novembre c'est à
dire qu'il s'est juste passé deux mois
jusqu'où pensez-vous que nous allons
aller dans cette réforme je le dis qui
souffre d'une impréparation chronique
dangereuse je rappelle que ça fait
comment dirais c'est un peu
l'hélicoptère améliard autour de France
compétences moi vraiment je vous pose la
question avec à la fois solennité
gravité et puis je garde non pas le
meilleur pour la fin parce que c'est pas
c'est pas le meilleur mais dans le
dernier PLFR de l'été enfin le précédent
puisque le dernier il arrive nous vous
avions mis en garde et nous avions fait
des propositions pour je dirais
resserrer la maille des économies
possibles et vous aviez balayé un
certain nombre d'amendements par des
objections
toutes plus étayer les unes que les
autres
il s'avère que vous venez d'annuler des
crédits pour 2 milliards d'euros pour
les appels en garantie près d'un
milliard sur la mission plan d'urgence
500 millions sur les dotations pour
dépenses accidentelles et imprévisibles
c'est à dire que finalement vous
proposez aujourd'hui les amendements que
le Sénat vous avez proposé et que vous
aviez refusé c'est un acte que je vais
appeler un peu de la part du
gouvernement de contrition mais
convenait que c'est un peu dommage
de ne pas avoir fait ce travail plus tôt
parce qu'il permetait et il aurait
permis d'être plus dans la réalité de la
vie dans la vérité des chiffres est-ce
que vous pouvez donc dans ce budget
rectificatif
identifier des annulations de crédit
parce que j'en ai pas vu jusqu'à
maintenant qui correspondrait par contre
un effort d'économie
merci Monsieur rapportage
de rajouter une question mais dans le
même sens mais
voilà vu sous l'autre angle annulation
de crédit bon je crois que le Rapporteur
général a dit tout ce que nous avions
pensé à l'époque et que nous avions
effectivement
sur sa proposition soutenue
est-ce qu'il y a pas la même question
que se pose sur les recettes c'est à
dire finalement est-ce qu'il y a pas
toujours vous savez ce ministre on est
toujours ici vous avez beaucoup de mères
si vous voulez
et les maires vont dire avec leur
directeur général des services ils ont
souvent un rôle c'est d'aller voir là où
le DGS a fait des poches oui bon et on
passe notre temps à discuter avec le DGS
pour dire des gentil tu te mets des
précautions mais voilà tu m'en parles là
tu m'en parles on le fait ensemble c'est
un débat permanent et sur les recettes
avec vous un peu de cette même
impression c'est-à-dire que on
sous-évalue au début d'ailleurs on vous
le dire n'est pas les seuls le Haut
Conseil souvent dit recette sont
peut-être un peu sous-estimés etc et
ensuite on les découvre
extraordinairement au bon moment
c'est-à-dire au moment où on a besoin
pour couvrir des dépenses trucs ça
ressemble
fâcheusement la théorie de la poche
voyez la poche de précaution enfin mais
non dite non affirmé et alors en plus
c'est revendu avec un discours très
positif sous l'angle nos politiques
réussissent ce qui est ce qui est quand
même comment dire le top
merci Monsieur le Ministre me dire si
c'est ça ou pas quoi en fait
je vous surprendrai pas dans la réponse
je préfère le dire tout de suite pour
pas qu'il faut suspense merci pour ces
questions je vais commencer par les
questions du rapporteur général la
première portée sur la prévision de
croissance maintenue à 2,7% pour 2027
qui a effectivement été jugé crédible
par le conseil aux finances publiques
vous avez indiqué que dans la foulée
l'Insee avait publié ces données qui
pouvaient laisser penser qu'il serait
plus difficile que prévu de l'attendre
je note que précédemment le Haut conseil
lors de la précédente prévision le
conseil aux finances publiques avait
jugé que cet objectif n'était pas
crédible pour 2022 les 2,5% et que le
lendemain l'Insee avait publié des
données qui avait confirmé la petite
croissance à 2,5%. mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a maintenu à
2,7% parce qu'on voit que l'activité
continue de progresser et notamment
s'agissant de l'investissement les
chiffres qui ont été communiqués par
l'INSEE sont très positifs de ce point
de vue là je crois que c'est une hausse
de 2, 10% mon équipe achera la tête
négativement si je me trompe mais 2,8%
au dernier trimestre qui est une
augmentation supérieure à celle que nous
avions connues au trimestre précédent et
c'est vrai que les dernières
informations dont on dispose il s'agit
pas de dire encore une fois que tout est
fleurissant il y a un certain nombre
d'aléas il y a des nuages qui
s'annonçaient aussi pour 2023 mais
témoigne plutôt d'une économie qui
résiste qui fait preuve d'une résilience
l'activité a continué de progresser au
troisième trimestre plus 0,2% après plus
0,5% au deuxième trimestre et ce malgré
les conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine
l'investissement des entreprises reste
vigoureux lui aussi je le disais à
l'instant la production manufacturière
progresse plus 0,6% nous avons réalisé
des premières enquêtes auprès des
entreprises sur le quatrième trimestre
elles sont toujours favorables puisque
en octobre le climat des affaires de
l'Insee est un niveau supérieur à la
normale à 102 contre une moyenne à 100
c'est toujours des statistiques qui sont
très global mais globalement l'Insee
note un climat qui est plus favorable ce
qui suggère une croissance toujours
dynamique il y a un aller à majeur qui
pèse on le sait sur la croissance dans
cette fin d'année c'est le risque d'une
rupture d'approvisionnement produit
énergétique or nos stocks de gaz sont
remplis à plein vous savez que c'est un
objectif qu'on poursuivait de manière
très forte c'est remplir à 100% nos
stocks de gaz avant l'arrivée dans
l'hiver ils sont remplis ce qui éloigne
ce risque d'avoir une rupture
d'approvisionnement cet hiver en matière
de gaz et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle le hcfp a jugé crédible notre
prévision de croissance 2022 qui est par
ailleurs proche des dernières prévisions
qui ont été publiées je crois que
l'INSEE la Banque de France le CDE et le
FCE sont à deux six et que le consensus
et le FMI est à 2,5 mais nous maintenons
notre
prévision à de 7 ces écarts sont quand
même très limités au regard des
incertitudes actuelles sur la deuxième
question sur les autorisations d'emploi
il y a effectivement un relèvement du
plafond de ministère à hauteur de 907 et
PPT au total c'est une évolution qui
s'explique essentiellement par la hausse
du plafond d'emploi le relèvement du
plafond d'emploi pour le ministère de la
Justice 691 eptp
vous savez qu'on a un objectif très fort
de réarmement du ministère de la Justice
le budget a augmenté de plus de 40 %
entre 2017 et 2023 et nous avons aussi
un objectif de relèvement du plafond
d'emploi 8500 postes supplémentaires de
magistrats de greffiers de personnels de
justice sont prévus pour le quinquennat
qui s'ouvre en l'occurrence c'est
création de postes 691 il y a tirer les
conséquences de la pérennisation du
renforcement de la lutte contre les
violences intrafamiliales les moyens
accordés également dans le cadre du
volet civil de la justice de proximité
il y a d'autres
ajustements techniques mais beaucoup
plus mineurs dans d'autres ministères et
cette correction effectuée en PLF de fin
de gestion sur la justice donnera
effectivement lieu je vous confirme sur
le rapporteur général c'était votre
question
un amendement de coordination en PLF
2023 pour ajuster le plafond du
ministère de la Justice d'autant il faut
toutefois attendre que le PLF soit
débattu et donc l'amendement au PLF 23
sera apporté plus tard au Sénat ou en
seconde lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
en fonction de l'examen du PLFR mais
c'est création rentrent dans le plafond
le relèvement du plafond d'emploi que
nous avons annoncé pour le quinquennat
pour le ministère de la Justice je crois
que nous sommes nombreux à nous
retrouver derrière cet objectif sur
France compétence oui je sais que c'est
un débat mais qui est légitime et
important on en avait eu l'occasion d'en
parler cet été au moment du PLFR 1 et je
vous le dis moi en tant que ministre du
Budget je considère aussi que la
situation n'est pas satisfaisante
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
devons poursuivre notre travail pour
apporter des économistes structurelles à
France compétences ils sont dans une
situation financière particulièrement
préoccupante principalement pour trois
raisons la première raison c'est le
succès de l'apprentissage le disait qui
conduit à une envolée des coûts contrats
des CFA que finance France compétences
pour plus de 10 milliards d'euros
désormais les dernières données d'Arès
disponibles mettent à montre à fin août
2022 une hausse de 13% des entrées en
apprentissage par rapport à la même
période en 2021 ce qui était déjà une
année historique deuxièmement il y a le
décollage du compte personnel de
formation qui est également financé par
France compétences pour désormais 3
milliards d'euros et enfin il y a des
recettes affectées avec la cuvepa qui
sont dynamiques à 10 milliards d'euros
mais pas assez pour couvrir le besoin de
financement et souffre de plusieurs
niches qui en atténue le rendement et
donc face à ce déséquilibre entre les
recettes qui sont contraintes qui sont
moins dynamiques que les et les dépenses
qui sont très dynamiques l'opérateur a
recouru à des empreintes court terme
mais qui deviennent onéreux avec la
remontée des taux d'intérêt il a
bénéficié de subventions exceptionnelle
pour l'étage rappelais 2 milliards 8 en
2021 4 milliards en 2022 avec ce PLFR et
encore un milliard 7 prévus en PLF en
PLF 23 on n'est pas au bout encore de
l'argent qu'on va rajouter à France
compétences en tout cas qu'on propose de
rajouter c'est subventions elles visent
tout simplement à éviter une rupture de
trésorerie chez France compétences qui
auraient pour conséquence de mettre en
difficulté les CFA ou le financement des
droits à la formation pour autant ça
n'est pas satisfaisant on est très
contents que notre pays ait fait
décoller l'apprentissage qu'on soit
passé de 300 000 jeunes en apprentissage
en 2017 sur une année à plus de 700 000
aujourd'hui c'est le fruit des réformes
qui ont été conduites et de ce soutien
je rappelle pas tout ce qui a été fait
en la matière pour simplifier
l'apprentissage et le recours pour
autant il faut apporter je le disais une
réponse structurelle pour assurer la
soutenabilité Financière de France
compétences et donc nous travaillons
depuis la rentrée plusieurs mesures
d'économie que je vais détailler
brièvement d'abord on a juste les coûts
contrats aux courriel de la formation
supportée par les CFA conformément aux
recommandations de la Cour des comptes
et du rapport puis ça ferait lévriers du
Sénat en juin 2022 inspire beaucoup des
rapports du Sénat évidemment c'était
précisément la proposition 19 de ce très
bon rapport et donc cette ajustement des
coûts contrats a débuté au mois de
septembre et ils permettra entre 2022
2023 une baisse de 10% des coûts
contrats dans les CFA ça fait une
économie de 800 millions d'euros cette
mesure a été adoptée en conseil
d'administration de France compétences
800 millions d'euros déjà sur les coûts
contrats des CFA ensuite nous souhaitons
mieux réguler le compte personnel de
formation c'est un formidable outil pour
garantir la formation des Français
l'acquisition de compétences on a
simplifier le droit à la formation c'est
beaucoup plus simple de la vie générale
d'avoir un compte en euros et panel de
formation qui sont accessibles en un
clic mais il faut évidemment limiter les
abus d'avoir faut limiter la fraude il y
en a beaucoup avec un texte qui a été
adopté sur le sujet et qu'on sanctionne
de mieux en mieux la fraude en la
matière il faut nettoyer du répertoire
des formations
des formations qui ont pas forcément
vocation à être financées par le compte
personnel de formation et donc sur ce
sujet là on avance aussi à l'Assemblée
nationale dans le cadre du 49-3 qui a
été
décidé par la première ministre sur la
partie 2 du PLF hier nous avons retenu
un amendement qui sera donc soumis à la
discussion au Sénat qui permet
l'instauration d'une participation
financière des bénéficiaires du compte
personnel de formation c'était là aussi
proposé par la Cour des comptes et par
le rapport sénatorial auquel je faisais
référence c'était la proposition numéro
11 et donc nous allons concerter avec
les partenaires sociaux évidemment avec
vous le montant de cette participation
mais mettre une participation financière
pour l'accès à la formation 1 c'est une
mesure de
entre guillemets enfin en tout cas
d'économie puisque c'est le moindre
dépense du compte personnel de formation
pour payer la formation mais ça permet
aussi d'assurer que les formations qui
sont assurées sont de vrais formations
et si je devais schématiser qu'on
finance pas des formations qui
consistent à remettre une clé USB au
bénéficiaire pour solde de tout compte
je caricature à des seins mais enfin il
y a quand même des choses qui se
rapprochent de ça donc participation
financière pour la formation dans le
cadre du CPF c'est adopté avec un
amendement ou 49,3 à l'Assemblée vous
allez en débattre il y a d'autres
mesures qui pourront venir compléter
utilement ce plan de redressement et je
le dis nous serons très attentifs aux
propositions que vous pourrez continuer
à faire sur ce sujet là
je termine pardon avec le sujet des
annulations de crédit
c'est d'abord un PLF de fin de gestion
classiquement je crois fait plutôt des
économies de constatation les choix
d'économie et que nous faisons nous les
faisons plutôt en PLF et donc oui il y a
une part d'économie de constatation et
je vous rejoins bien volontiers monsieur
le rapporteur général pour dire que une
partie de ces économies de constatation
avait été vous les anticipiez cet été en
nous disant voilà vous lisez cet été il
faut pas mettre autant sur ces
enveloppes puisque probablement vous
annulerez tout ou partie des crédits si
on prend les dépenses sur le plan
d'urgence c'était effectivement le cas
mais je crois que nous annulons 500
millions là où il y avait dans
l'enveloppe prévu
un peu plus un milliard je crois donc on
allume on annule pas l'intégralité du
milliard mais une partie d'une bonne
nouvelle on n'a pas eu besoin d'utiliser
cet argent mais c'est vrai et je vous le
reconnais que vous aviez signalé signalé
ce point sur la question des 2 milliards
d'appels en garantie je n'ai pas cité
tout à l'heure c'est aussi un bon signe
pour l'économie française c'est un bon
signe qu'il y ait moins de défaillance
que ce qui était anticipé ou redouté et
que l'appel en garantie de l'État pour
des PGE d'entreprises défaillante était
moins sollicité c'est quand même plutôt
bon signe c'est 2 milliards d'économies
à ce titre et c'est vrai qu'on avait
prévu anticipé redouté qui est plus de
défaillances d'entreprises et ça n'est
pas le cas enfin monsieur le Président
rénal je vais pas vous surprendre non on
ne sous-évalue pas les recettes on
essaye de viser au plus juste et
d'ailleurs je suis sûr que si on
prévoyait des recettes on va dire très
importantes ou assez vite on remettrait
en doute nos prévisions et on nous
dirait vous boucler un sol de
prévisionnel de déficit en gonflant des
recettes prévisionnelles en réalité vous
n'arriverez pas à obtenir de telles
recettes c'est objectivement la
prévision est toujours très difficile il
y a un certain nombre d'aléas qui pèsent
sur l'économie française une guerre au
coeur de l'Europe une crise
internationale sur les prix de l'énergie
l'inflation qui est de retour
massivement dans le monde entier ça
incite quand même à une forme de
prudence et on essaye d'être au plus
juste et quand on a des roses des bonnes
nouvelles en l'occurrence sur les
recettes et sur l'impôt sur les sociétés
comme on l'a eu ces derniers mois c'est
plutôt bon signe sur la vitalité de
l'économie française mais si on avait pu
prévoir ces recettes évidemment on
l'aurait fait
merci Monsieur le Ministre
Didier Rambaud puis Vincent Delahaye
merci président monsieur le ministre
donc vous venez de décliner ce PFR avec
diverses mesures de soutien confirmé ou
de nouvelles et j'ai bien noté notamment
donc votre annonce d'un mécanisme de
soutien pour les universités les
opérateurs de recherche les CROUS pour
leur permettre de faire face aux
dépenses d'énergie un fond donc de j'ai
bien noté de 275 millions d'euros alors
comme parlementaire isèrerois je me suis
effectivement très attentif à ce à cette
annonce puisque voilà à Grenoble il y a
un campus universitaire des centres de
recherche très importants je ne vais pas
manquer d'être interrogé maintenant sur
la mécanique de ce de cette annonce
comment c'était de va se décomposer
comment elle va être répartie entre les
les différents opérateurs donc est-ce
que vous pouviez nous nous en préciser
un petit peu le fonctionnement et les
conditions d'attribution je vous
remercie
merci Didier Vincent Delahaye puis
Christine et Lavarde
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre
alors moi je reviens un tout petit peu
sur les recettes poches de précaution ou
pas en tout cas c'est un argument que
j'avais avancé en 2021 lorsque on avait
fait le PDF 2021 et que les recettes
avaient largement été sous-évalués pour
pouvoir avoir de bonnes nouvelles avant
les élections présidentielles alors moi
ça ne m'avait pas échappé en tout cas ce
qui ne va pas échappé c'est qu'à chaque
fois sur les recettes on a assez peu de
documentation sur les hypothèses qui
sont retenues pour évaluer les recettes
quand on cherche dans les documents on
en trouve assez peu moi j'aimerais
vraiment qu'on ait plus de détails je
sais pas si le rapporteur a réussi en
avoir pour 2023 pour le pélèbre 2023
parce que mon sentiment c'est
qu'effectivement on a un peu sous-évalué
en 2021 2022 et je pense qu'on a un peu
surévalué pour 2023 je vous donne mon
sentiment on verra ce que on verra le
résultat à l'arrivée mais mon sentiment
c'est que le 1% de croissance il va être
difficile à atteindre en 2023 et que
dans ces conditions
on verra au niveau des recettes mais
j'espère qu'on aura le détail sur les
investissements vous moi je me réjou
aussi que les investissements augmentent
de 2,8% mais j'aimerais bien avoir la
distinction entre investissement
financier et investissement productif
c'est pour moi les investissements
productifs depuis pas mal de temps ont
plutôt tendance à baisser et c'est ce
qui m'inquiète le plus je dirais que les
investissements financiers augmentent on
est dans un monde financière avec
beaucoup de dettes c'est assez classique
mais ce qui a de plus intéressant c'est
les investissements productifs alors moi
je m'inquiète aussi bien sûr sur les
dépenses de France compétences
ça a été largement dit
moi ça m'interpelle c'est les dépenses
de guichet guichet est ouvert allez-y
messieurs dames 8000 euros aux
entreprises on prend pas toujours les
personnes qu'on devrait prendre en
apprentissage parce que c'est pas
toujours la bonne cible je pense qu'on
si là les grosses dépenses et surtout
sur des apprentissages de d'enseignement
supérieur ou finalement c'est assez
facile et sur les sur ceux qui sont les
plus éloignés de l'emploi c'est là où
c'est le plus difficile et je pense que
on fait pas assez d'effort là dessus
donc il y a un effet d'aubaine
je suis peut-être un orthodoxe mais moi
j'ai tendance à ne pas dépenser plus que
ce que je gagne donc et dans tous les
domaines donc j'essaie j'essaye de me
dire je j'ai une politique pour
l'apprentissage je fixe un manteau
annuel et vous devez pas le dépasser
voilà il y a pas un guichet il y a un
moment donné ou stop les crédits sont
sautés puisés et on n'est pas là à
guichet ouvert en tout cas je l'ai déjà
dénoncé pour l'aide médicale d'État
l'ame d'ailleurs j'ai pas encore regardé
ce qui se passait pour 2023 pour l'ame
mais ces dépenses de guichet moi je ça
me gêne toujours
alors j'ai posé une question parce que
là j'ai fait plutôt des constatations et
observations mais sur sur la question
c'est sur les collectivités
territoriales il y a un bouclier qui a
été voté au mois d'août
il me semble que ce bouclier va pas
toucher autant de communes que ce qui a
été annoncé mais vous pouvez peut-être
nous en dire quelque chose il était
prévu qu'on dépense à milliard 5
combien combien on va dépenser
réellement et est-ce que
est-ce que ce qui est prévu pour 2023 le
milliard supplémentaire sur quels
critères vous allez arrêter ce soutien
en collectivité territoriale
merci Vincent Christine Lavarde puis
Vanina paoliga
merci monsieur le Président alors
Monsieur le Ministre j'aurai deux
questions la première est relative au
bouclier tarifaire pour les EHPAD
puisque là vous venez de nous parler des
universités de l'armée enfin de tout un
tas de secteurs pour lequel on apporte
des mesures complémentaires j'ai cru
comprendre que le gouvernement a pris
des engagements vis-à-vis des états
alors je m'excuse parce que c'est
peut-être à cheval entre le plfs dont on
va bientôt discuter certaines mesures du
PLF 2023 mais il y a quand même la
question qui reste à solder c'est 2022
pour lequel je des crédits pour moi
doivent être pris sur 2022 dans ce texte
là je vois rien donc comment le
gouvernement compte aider ce secteur qui
en plus pour le coup est un secteur qui
est quand même assez contraint dans ses
possibilités de faire des économies
d'énergie enfin malheureusement une
personne âgée alitée on va pas pouvoir
la mettre dans une chambre à 15 degrés
fin voilà c'est on n'est pas dans le
même dans les mêmes possibilités que
pour des gymnases ou autres donc ça
c'était ma première question
ma seconde question porte sur l'article
2 alors c'est un sujet sur lequel je
reviens régulièrement votre prédécesseur
doit avoir une des archives sur toutes
les questions que j'ai pu lui poser ou
les courriers que j'ai pu lui envoyer
alors déjà je constate que la
l'étude d'impact de l'article comme
d'habitude ne mentionne pas les effets
pour les collectivités alors juste pour
mes collègues l'article 2 il vient en
fait remodifier des versements à
l'intérieur du casse radar voilà et donc
ce castradar il y a une partie des
sommes qui est reversée aux
collectivités en fonction du point de la
menthe de la menthe de police et donc
plus on fait des prélèvements au titre
de la fit moins la somme qui est ensuite
possible d'être reversée aux
collectivités diminue et à l'intérieur
de cette somme il y a une question qui
nous intéresse qui est les communes de
plus de 10000 habitants de la région
Île-de-France qui elle se voit obligée
de reverser depuis la dépénalisation du
stationnement un menton fixe à
Île-de-France mobilité et à la région
Île-de-France qui a été calculée sur le
constaté 2017 donc on a plus la
dynamique pour ces communes par contre
on a quelque chose de fixe et donc
aujourd'hui enfin qu'est-ce qui se passe
en fait qu'est-ce que cet article va
faire pour les collectivités
c'est-à-dire que et donc j'ai une
dernière question toujours en lien avec
ce casque à l'Assemblée nationale j'ai
vu qu'un des collègues avait proposé un
amendement de suppression du casse qui
était la solution notamment pour venir
avoir des flux beaucoup plus simple à
l'intérieur de cette enveloppe entre
d'un côté le financement de la fuite de
l'autre côté le financement des
collectivités et ce qui reste ensuite
pour l'étal cet amendement n'a pas été
retenu de dans le 49-3 pourtant j'avais
cru comprendre que c'était une solution
qui était préconisée par la partie
budget
ministère du budget du gouvernement donc
à dire ce que vous avez encore perdu
l'arbitrage cette fois-ci
merci Christine
Vanina pas
oliac merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre merci pour cette
présentation je partage tout à fait vos
propos sur l'impératif de confiance
c'est pourquoi j'ai besoin juste de
comprendre mieux comprendre peut-être le
sens et la portée des fonds d'une part
de compensation et d'autre part de
crédit frais pour les universités et les
organismes de recherche
pour le premier le fond de compensation
des coûts de l'énergie alors sauf
mauvaise compréhension de ma part il me
semble que c'est pour compenser les
coûts de l'énergie en 2023
si tel est le cas en fait je comprends
pas bien pourquoi c'est ouvert en PLFR
pour 2022 et non pas en PLF pour 2023 ce
qui aurait été peut-être plus lisible
pour nous
et sur le fond qui est doté de 275
millions d'euros il me semble qu'en fait
c'est seulement 150 millions d'euros de
crédit frais qui qui sont en réalité
ouverts dans votre projet de loi de
finance rectificatif mais là encore j'ai
besoin que vous confortiez ou non cette
interprétation les 125 complémentaires
seraient pris d'une part sur les crédits
de la réserve de précautions pardon des
opérateurs de recherche et d'autre part
sur les crédits dégagés par
l'abaissement du nombre de boursiers
ça veut dire que finalement ce fond de
275 millions d'euros c'est un fond de
150 millions d'euros donc je vous
remercie de nous apporter vos éclairages
sur ces chiffres merci Vanina Christian
Billac puis Vincent segun
merci monsieur le Président
rénal je croirait un peu
[Musique]
au conseil municipal quand on découvre
les poires pour la soif après
effectivement on a quelques petits
trésors cachés là qu'on découvre enfin à
tout prendre moi je préfère
une surestimation de dépenses et je vous
a été machin des recettes que l'inverse
voilà je suis je l'ai dit plus
pessimiste pour 2023 moi aussi et à tout
prendre ma foi il vaut mieux avoir pu le
recettes et moi je dépense que l'inverse
voilà j'aurais trois chiffres qui
m'interpellent un peu avec quelques
réflexions là-dessus sur le plan de
relance on a un équilibre à 298 millions
d'euros avaient moins 290 millions sur
l'écologie et plus de 198 sur la
compétitivité la cohésion
alors hier dans votre intervention vous
avez évoqué monsieur ministre les
accompagnateurs en matière du de ma
prime rénov et de toutes les travaux
liés au climat
si vous permettez monsieur le ministre
je vais être un peu de fluvial ce ne
sont pas les accompagnateurs que vous
avez mais les emmerdeurs
des emmerdes
je suis à mon troisième maçon qui
abandonne la qualification RGE parce que
il n'en peuvent plus
de nature quotidienne auquel il doit
faire face et j'ai fait au troisième
que je passe parce que chaque fois il me
dit qu'il abandonnèrent je veux parce
que c'est intenable et c'est une
lourdeur incroyable et donc là il y a
quelque chose qui peut-être expliquer
c'est au 198 millions d'annulation qui
n'ont pas été consommés parce que sur le
terrain il y a des artisans et il y a
beaucoup de particuliers qui abandonnent
face à la complexité du montage du
dossier pour ma part il a duré 17 mois
le montage du dossier et pardonnez-moi
avec plus de trois décennies de mandats
de mer je crois savoir à peu près monter
les dossier 17 mois voilà donc ça c'est
de la première remarque la deuxième
question c'était les dépenser
imprévisible et accidentelle donc ça
effectivement c'est pas le prévoir mais
là vous annuler 500 millions d'euros
est-ce qu'il en reste un peu parce qu'on
est quand même que
début novembre les choses imprévisibles
peuvent arriver à tout moment donc voilà
donc qui disparaissent là je savoir si
on a quand même un filet de sécurité et
la dernière question c'est le concours
financier aux collectivités locales où
on enlève 80 millions d'euros dans la
chambre de crédit et là aussi monsieur
le ministre
de l'ombre mer me dit que c'est très
compliqué parce que ils doivent déposer
les dossiers avant la fin de l'année
mais après il reçoivent les
notifications pour la bsel ou la doter
quand juillet août noir septembre et
donc là il est très difficile au moment
du vote du budget de savoir sur l'inter
ou pas et quand on reçoit nos
modifications en juillet ou septembre le
temps de lancer l'appel d'offre et de
mettre en route la machine
administrative et bien l'année était
coulée voilà donc moi j'appelle un peu
plus de réactivité et je dirais de
compréhension du terrain qui est souvent
n'arrive pas à consommer les crédits par
par difficulté administratives
merci Christian Vincent Segoin puis
Vincent capo canela
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre trois questions
la première vous avez fait une remarque
intéressante je vous avais dit que le
chèque carburant irait dorénavant au
travail je voulais juste savoir comment
vous allez régler la question
puisqu'on a quand même un taux de
chômage qui est encore très élevé et je
lisais ce matin aussi que les Français
roulaient sur tout le weekend donc on
risque de faire des grosses économies le
deuxième point c'est par rapport au CPF
j'aimerais que vous nous rappeliez quel
était l'objectif du CPF et savoir si
vous avez un indice de résultat sur
l'objectif fixé parce que on entend
beaucoup de controverses sur le sujet et
des fonds moi je rejoins le rapporteur
général quand il dit que c'est un
puissant fond le troisième point c'était
sur le PGE
vous dites on est assez satisfait parce
que le taux de contentieux ne pas
augmenté pas plus tard que la semaine
dernière je suis intervenu sur le sujet
parce que certes on regarde le taux de
contentieux mais il y a d'autres
critères qui font regarder c'est le
nombre de radiations de sociétés qui est
en hausse de façon
vertigineuse et la chute des trésorerie
donc par rapport à ça est-ce que vous
êtes attentif par rapport à ces critères
merci
merci Vincent Vincent capo canela merci
monsieur le Président merci d'avoir
monsieur le ministre sa présentation
j'ai une question sur le cadrage un peu
global de la politique budgétaire du
gouvernement et également en parallèle
la politique monétaire bon à chaque PLF
et PLFR on est évidemment confronté un
dilemme qui est bien sûr de prendre en
compte la situation économique les
crises c'est s'adapter de ne pas casser
la croissance de répondre
aux attentes de nos compatriotes qui
sont évidemment légitimes face à face
notamment à l'inflation et donc on est
plutôt sur une politique budgétaire
disons accommodante et même si là le
solde s'améliore légèrement on reste
dans cette logique budgétaire un peu
dépensière et en face de ça avec
l'inflation il y a la remontée des taux
on le voit alors vous me direz peut-être
que les taux réels sont pas ce que l'on
croit ou ce que l'on dit et que
effectivement il faut la relativiser
mais est-ce qu'on peut rester longtemps
avec une politique monétaire qui se dit
ou qui se veut rester ici et une
politique budgétaire qui reste
accommodante
merci Vincent Daniel Breuillet puis
Stéphane Sautarel
merci merci monsieur le ministre de
cette présentation comme comme mes
voisins et collègues je me félicite des
crédits annoncés côté universitaire
j'avais aussi attiré l'attention sur la
situation des universités par ailleurs
avec des locaux souvent très très
vétustes université CROUS j'y rajoute
d'ailleurs les les hôpitaux qui comme
les EHPAD ont des considérations
particulières mais je j'attends avec
impatience aussi vos explications sur
les modalités et les précisions parce
que concernant le bouclier énergétique
des collectivités l'annonce était
généreuse mais la traduction ne l'était
pas pour l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales en tous les cas pas pour
les 8000 plus importantes deuxième
remarque c'est sur France compétences
comme je suis co-rapporter avec mon
collègue Emmanuel Capu de la mission
travail emploi
je dois dire qu'à sans doute des
des améliorations apportées pour ma part
l'idée qu'elle apprentissage soit sur
des crédits ouverts c'est en réponse à
Vincent nomme choque pas parce que pour
le coup il y a un succès je donne pas
toujours des satisfaits sites au
gouvernement donc je me permets d'en
donner un par contre je pense qu'il y a
revoir les modalités parce que tu as
raison Vincent traiter de la même façon
les bacs + 3 et les bacs - 3 ça n'est
pas certain qu'il y ait la même
nécessité évidemment d'accompagnement
dans l'apprentissage des gens qui sont
déjà très formés et prêts à l'emploi et
des gens qui sont évidemment beaucoup
plus éloignés donc mais on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir enfin ma question
centrale est la suivante vous annoncez
des prolongations sur les boucliers
carburants bouclier tarifaire etc
moi je pense que c'est boucliers au fond
sont
impossibles à soutenir sur la durée
écologiquement plus que discutable et
même en termes d'équité ils sont assez
discutables quand on regarde au fond qui
bénéficie de quel montant de crédit et
donc il faudrait qu'on passe et c'est ma
question comment est-ce qu'on passe
d'une analyse ou sur une crise on met
des réponses ponctuelles à une
considération que la crise est durable
et n'est pas n'est pas temporelle et
donc qui appelle plutôt des réponses de
résilience et c'est vrai que par exemple
il vaut quand même mieux isoler les
logements que subventionné le chauffage
et des courants d'air qui a à
l'extérieur j'ai entendu hier le débat
vous m'avez un peu attristé sur la
caricature du vote nupes moi je crois
pas qu'on puisse faire 10 milliards
d'investissements immédiatement sur la
rénovation thermique par exemple mais
j'avais défendu ça que il fallait
changer les ordres de grandeur et plutôt
mettre 10 milliard sur la rénovation
thermique pour faire de la vraie
rénovation thermique et sortir de la
dépendance que nous avons au fossiles et
par ailleurs de la précarité énergétique
de nombreux ménages il faut accompagner
ça évidemment enfin de toutes les façons
mais ma question c'est comment sortir de
ces boucliers encore une fois ponctuel
la crise est durable et donc il faut
plutôt des mesures liées à cette
durabilité de la crise qui soit des
mesures de résilience pour l'ensemble
des bénéficiaires et peut-être des
mesures aussi ont différencie les
premiers mètres cubes ou les premiers
kilowatt-heure de consommation pour les
rendre accessibles à tous aisément et
puis on laisse le vrai prix de marché
voir un prix accru pour les
kilowatt-heure ou les ou les enfin les
oui enfin pour les montants d'énergie
sur ce qu'on pourrait appeler du confort
et qui n'est pas la même chose on doit
permettre à tout le monde de chauffer on
n'est pas obligé de permettre à tout le
monde de dépenser énormément
merci
Daniel Stephen sauterelle puis Isabelle
briquet oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre juste deux
questions une sur le sujet des
collectivités territoriales qui a déjà
été abordé puisque dans le LFR 1 un
certain nombre de crédits avaient été
voté au regard de ce qui semble mise à
oeuvre sur le terrain et et des critères
n'aurait presque pu s'attendre de
manière provocante dans ce plfr2 à avoir
des réductions de crédit quand il semble
que le nombre de bénéficiaires les
conditions d'éligibilité ne soit pas
tout à fait à la hauteur des attentes
donc j'aurais aimé que vous nous
apportiez des réponses sur ce sur ce
point-là pour savoir si l'objectif de
soutien des collectivités qui avait été
mise en place dans le PLF 1 va être
traduit de manière concrète sur le
terrain puisque aujourd'hui on se heurte
à deux à de grandes difficultés et ma
deuxième question elle effectivement les
crédits qui sont rajoutés au titre des
carburants donc vous l'avez indiqué avec
une première mesure jusqu'à mi-novembre
puis qui maintient les 30 centimes puis
les 10 centimes jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2022 et je voulais vous
interroger moi en fait ça dépasse le
cadre du PLF 2 mais au-delà sur ce que
vous appelez les gros rouleurs gros
rouleurs travailleurs mais je voulais
aussi insister sur la dimension
territoriale de ses besoins on a pu
constater dans différents documents
qu'en particulier au niveau de la charge
énergétique pour les ménages il y a un
écart considérable entre les urbains et
les ruraux et au niveau des carburants
il en est de même et c'est même encore
davantage amplifié donc j'aurais
souhaité que vous puissiez nous apaiser
ou en tout cas nous apporter des
réponses sur la manière dont ceux qui ne
peuvent pas se passer de carburant
pourront être accompagnés au-delà du 1er
janvier 2023 merci merci Stéphane
donc Isabelle briquet puis Christian
Klinger
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre une question un peu en marge
mais quoi que aujourd'hui donc nous
examinons un second PLFR nous sommes en
plein examen du PLF et pourtant aucun
nouveau projet de loi de règlement ne
nous a été présenté depuis son rejet cet
été il me semble que ce texte devait
être validé en amont de la discussion de
nouveaux textes budgétaires où
j'aimerais simplement avoir votre avis à
ce sujet et à savoir si nous aurons
examiné un nouveau projet de loi de
règlement des comptes 2021 avant de
débuter l'exercice 2023
merci Isabelle Christian kinger puis
Michel canvett pour conclure les
questions je crois
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre vous avez fait mention
effectivement dans le cas de CPF de une
ouverture de crédit de 2 milliards sur
le programme relatifs rémunération
publique vous avez mentionné que pour
l'État il avait la création de 907
équivalentin dont temps plein pardon
dans 691 pour le ministère de la Justice
là-dessus je pense que il n'y a pas trop
de débats par contre il y a eu aussi la
création de 174 équivalent tôt plein
temps plein pour les opérateurs de
l'État donc 80 pour la RS alors certes
l'ARS se voit confier dans les deux ans
qui viennent une nouvelle mission sur le
contrôle des EHPAD mais est-ce que cela
n'aurait pas pu se faire en réaffectant
du personnel existant on est à la fin de
la pandémie on peut supposer que les
effectifs de l'ARS sont quand même bien
fournis et on réaffectant du personnel
sans embauche sans embauche on aurait pu
donner cette mission on voit aussi la
création de 53 équivalente temps plein
pour les services du Premier ministre en
termes de sobriété n'aurait pu faire
mieux plus globalement pour le non
régalien est-ce que on pourrait pas
gérer les effectifs de manière plus
serrée et plus sérieuse
merci Christian Michel canette merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègue on peut se
réjouir que l'amélioration du solde dans
ce PLF 2 soit effectivement
mais on a quand même pu expérimenté
quand même quelques sujets d'inquiétude
en tout cas nous au niveau du groupe de
l'Union centrée dans les extrêmes on l'a
déjà fait pour ce qui concerne l'aide au
carburant parce qu'ils ne nous semblait
pas appropriés
que ce soit dépense de guichet comme à
évoqué Vincent Delahaye tout à l'heure
mais qu'il fallait plutôt cibler sur
ceux qui ont besoin pour aller au
travail et je pense que la sortie sera
particulièrement difficile moi quand
j'ai fait le plein lundi c'était 1,90 le
carburant donc avec la remise de 30
centimes de 30 centimes ça va faire deux
vins deux vins lorsqu'il n'y aura plus
les aides de l'État inutile de dire que
dans nos campagnes la situation va être
extrêmement compliquée parce que lorsque
c'était à 1,50 on a connu la crise des
gilets jaunes donc je vous laisse
imaginer la situation dans laquelle on
va se retrouver très bientôt donc il va
y avoir intérêt à trouver des solutions
pour que ceux qui ont absolument besoin
de la voiture pour aller travailler plus
de faire sans que à la fin du mois ça
leur compte soit totalement
déséquilibrés et dans les deux même un
peu pour le secteur de la pêche qui est
affronté à la difficulté parce que
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'autres moyens
de motorisation des navires que le
recours au fioul au carburant et donc
ils sont obligés d'aller d'utiliser le
carburant et aujourd'hui
on a les plus vite inquiétudes et sans
doute que la sainte bateaux vont devoir
rester hacké parce que économiquement il
ne sera plus tenable de pouvoir sortir
avec un prix du fioul qui dépassera les
1 euro
le litre donc on a un certain nombre de
sujets devant nous alors hier nous
évoquions la loi de programmation des
finances publiques monsieur le ministre
nous étions assez inquiet quand même sur
les créations de postes m'ont certes
dans notre program stabilité des
effectifs mais on voit déjà que dans le
PLF 2023 on est à plus près de 10000
créations de poste et puis ici dans la
loi de finances rectificative on est un
peu moins de 1000 on est à 907
on se dit
il y a toujours de bonnes raisons pour
créer des emplois donc la question de la
stabilité des effectifs dans la haute
finance va être difficile dans la
programmation des finances va être
difficile à tenir avec les toujours les
bonnes raisons qu'il y a de créer des
postes on le voit au niveau de l'ARS je
pense que les effectifs de l'ARS ont été
significativement augmenté au niveau de
la pandémie mais là on en rajoute encore
en loi de finance rectificative un
certain nombre de postes donc ce sont
des dépenses et des dépenses de
fonctionnement qui vont être récurrentes
et qui vont donc peser sur nos comptes à
l'avenir donc il faut que l'on soit très
attentif à ça l'exemple doit venir du
haut parce que quand on crée 50 postes
de cabinet de plus il y a certainement
de bonnes raisons mais
dans la gestion au quotidien de nos
comptes
ça fait des charges supplémentaires et
l'exemple n'est donc pas montrer de
là-haut et ça c'est un vrai sujet
d'inquiétude alors
nous nous avions pensé proposé la taxe
sur les papiers j'ai reviens parce que
pour autant tout le monde apprécie que
l'État soit particulièrement présent
auprès de tous ceux qui sont en
difficulté mais il faut qu'on change à
nos grands publics aussi et je crois
qu'il faut pas avoir de doc une balade
dessus monsieur le ministre et il faut
admettre que à situation exceptionnelle
on constate qu'ensemble de ton
entreprise vont bien et et ça rejaillit
sur le niveau de l'impôt sur les
sociétés on s'en réjouit tous mais mais
quand même il faut que face à cette
situation compte tenu de l'effort que
fait l'Etat Corneille aussi des recettes
exceptionnelles qui soient
récupéré de façon à éviter la
dégradation du sol parce que la
dégradation du solde c'est un budget qui
termine à plus de 160 milliards de
déficits on va pas pouvoir durer
longtemps comme ça parce qu'à un moment
où on arrivera plus à trouver l'argent
qui nous est nécessaire pour pouvoir
boucher le trou et rembourser des prêts
qui arrivent à échéance
attention au défaut de paiement il peut
nous guetter un jour ou l'autre à la
confiance peut tomber parce que un
certain nombre de circonstances etc et
nous mettre en très grande difficulté
donc il faut qu'on soit attentif et que
on veille à ce que nos dépenses soient
les plus rigoureuses possibles et que on
ne se prive pas de recette
exceptionnelle c'est normal que un
certain nombre de participer à l'effort
en même temps que l'État accompagne les
plus en difficulté
merci Michel monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président merci à tous
beaucoup de questions sur de nombreux
sujets je vais m'efforcer d'y répondre
dans le détail première question c'était
Didier Rambaud sur le fond d'aide aux
universités pour leur facture d'énergie
et je répondrai par la même occasion à
Vanina paoliagen qui a également
interrogé sur ce sujet là oui il y a
bien 150 millions d'euros de ce que vous
appelez crédit frais c'est un effort
majeur en ouverture auquel s'ajoute les
forts de marge existantes sur les
programmes qui auraient pu sinon être
annulés c'est pour ça que la distinction
entre crédit frais pas frais le faité
qu'il y a des crédits qui auraient pu
par des économies de constatation être
annulées qui ne le sont pas pour venir
alimenter ce fond et en crédit frais il
y a 150 millions d'euros
supplémentaires même durant la crise
covid on avait annulé en fin de gestion
sur le ministère de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche avec
notamment des sous-exécutions sur les
bourses c'est un choix qui avait été
fait là on fait un choix inverse
manière de solliciter ces fonds pour les
universités je renvoie vraiment aux
précisions qu'apportera ma collègue
Sylvie rotaillod elle les travaille
justement en ce moment même avec les
opérateurs des universités et de la
recherche pour préciser tout cela
c'est je vous parlais de 2022 à
l'instant ça a donc vocation à soutenir
à couvrir les surcoûts 2022 mais aussi
en 2023 et donc ce qu'on a déjà arbitré
c'est qu'il y aurait un versement de
temps le premier de manière homogène
selon les surcos qui sont observés fin
22 et le second en tenant compte de la
situation financière des établissements
et donc la partie qui n'aura pas été
versée en 2022 sera reporté sur 2023
mais à nouveau sur le calibrage ça reste
en cours du côté de Sylvie retaillod qui
pourra vous donner davantage de détails
sur ce sujet je passe ensuite aux
questions de Monsieur Delahaye qui est
là sur la question des j'essaye de me
relier plus de détails documentation sur
les recettes effectivement dans le
détail il y a le voisin tome 1 et le
rapport économique social et financier
qui détaille les recettes mais pas
nécessairement et c'est vrai je vous
l'accorde le sous-jacent des prévisions
il y a souvent des questions des
rapporteurs généraux qui sont posés sur
le sujet et on s'efforce dit répondre
ce que je peux vous dire c'est deux
choses en effectivement si nous venions
à ne pas atteindre l'objectif d'un pour
cent de croissance de fait ça se
ressentirait dans les recettes par
définition à la prévision de recettes et
aussi liée à la prévision de croissance
que nous fixons dans le texte sur le
volet sécurité sociale nous prenons
l'hypothèse d'une augmentation de la
masse salariale en 2023 de 5% après 8,6%
en 2022 et ça explique par exemple une
hausse de 22,7 milliards d'euros des
cotisations sociales en 2023 après plus
26,8 milliards d'euros en 2022 pour vous
donner un sous-jacent sur une partie des
recettes sur
ensuite la question de France
compétences
et il y a des primes apprentissage alors
vous avez vous avez mentionné les primes
à l'embauche pour les employeurs sur
l'apprentissage c'est primes ne sont pas
financées par France compétences mais
sur le budget de l'État ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas faire des économies et
là-dessus je suis aussi un promoteur
d'économie en la matière d'ailleurs les
crédits que nous avons alloués au
ministère du Travail pour financer les
primes apprentissage
ne correspondent pas au crédit
nécessaire pour couvrir les besoins
d'apprentissage avec le même niveau et
le même montant de prime ça veut dire
que le ministère du travail va devoir
est d'ailleurs il a commencé à le faire
travailler en concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux un nouveau barème
des primes c'est vraiment mon collègue
Olivier du soft qui a annoncera le
nouveau montant il y a plusieurs
possibilités soit une diminution globale
des primes accordées aux employeurs soit
raisonner en niveau de formation est-ce
que pour les masters par exemple il faut
garder un tel niveau de soutien ou pas
voilà chacun peut avoir un avis sur la
question j'en ai un pas totalement
l'externalisé ici c'est des discussions
d'interministérielles mais je pense que
il faut garder un niveau de soutien
important pour ceux qui sont en dessous
du bac et peut-être jusqu'à bac + 2 Bac
+3 pour les BTS IUT garder un tel niveau
de soutien pour des masters je suis pas
certain que ça soit nécessaire par
ailleurs ce qu'on note quand même et je
crois qu'il y a eu aussi des travaux
sénatorio sur le sujet c'est quand même
que le décollage de l'apprentissage on
doit évidemment à ce qui a été fait dans
le cadre du plan de relance avec des
primes très importantes mais en réalité
quand on regarde le décollage a commencé
avant alors c'est une courte période
donc il faut vraiment le regarder film
mais en réalité le décollage il a
démarré au moment où on a fait l'aide
d'unique à l'apprentissage qui était pas
du tout d'un montant de 8000 euros par
contrat qui était plutôt autour d'un peu
au dessus de 4000 euros je crois mais
dès lors qu'on a simplifié les choses
qu'on a fait la dunique on a déjà
observé un décollage donc je ne pense
pas que revoir à la baisse le barème des
primes à l'apprentissage entraînerait un
effondrement de l'apprentissage dans
notre pays je crois pas du tout mais
donc c'est un travail qui est engagé par
notre mon collègue Olivier du soft
encore une fois il y a des économies à
faire sur France compétences et sur le
CPF
voilà là aussi je pense qu'on aura des
débats et que les travaux qui ont été
faits par le Sénat dans le rapport
sénatorial sont assez éclairants il y a
des formations on se demande si elles
doivent être financées sur le CPF voilà
8 millions d'euros pour des formations
pour pratiquer des massages bien-être
alors c'est un détail c'est 8 millions
d'euros enfin je veux dire est-ce que ça
a vocation être financé sur France
compétences je ne sais pas c'est
important d'avoir des masseurs bien-être
dans notre pays mais est-ce que ça doit
être financé par le compte personnel de
formation ça ça pose question des
formations en sophrologie pour 11
millions d'euros est-ce que ça doit
aussi être financer ou pas c'est des
petits montants mais enfin quand vous
mettez bout à bout des formations qui
posent question on arrive à des gros
montants voilà il y a d'autres questions
qui se posent alors là on est sur des
montants beaucoup plus gros et pour le
coup je pense que la question se pose
plus et il y a plus de bas mais par
exemple sur les tests de langue je crois
que c'est je regarde mon équipe vous me
dites si je me trompe 500 millions
d'euros c'est ça test de langue on sait
qu'il y a beaucoup de nos concitoyens
qui ont besoin d'un test de langue
tamponné pour accéder à certaines
certains métiers est-ce que pour autant
un test de langue vient vous faire
acquérir une compétence il y a plutôt la
faire certifier donc la question se pose
aussi sur ce sujet là tout est tas de
cause il y a des économies prévues
encore une fois sur les coûts contrats
et pour le CPF avec une participation
financière et on aura l'occasion dans
des battre dans le dans le cadre du PLF
sur les collectivités territoriales vous
m'avez interrogé monsieur Delahaye
monsieur sotarel m'a interrogé aussi et
d'autres sur le filet de sécurité le
filet de sécurité que vous avez voté en
2022 dans le PLF cet été était de 430
millions d'euros pour les collectivités
locales le 1 milliard 5 c'est le filet
qui est prévu pour 2023 en plus du
bouclier qui a été annoncé par la
première ministre qui va bénéficier aux
collectivités locales sur le filet de
sécurité de 430 millions d'euros se
souvient je vais pas rappeler les
critères ils sont assez techniques mais
ils ont aussi été travaillés avec la
porte du rapporteur général de la
majorité sénatoriale qui a fait évoluer
dispositif qui avait été adopté à
l'unanimité de l'Assemblée nationale et
proposer au départ par une député
socialiste madame pierresbonne qui
connaît très bien
le financement des collectivités locales
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que deux
semaines après le lancement du
dispositif puisque le décret est paru il
y a deux semaines mais services de la
Direction générale des finances
publiques ont pris contact avec 8500
collectivités je leur ai demandé de
faire du proactif de pas attendre que
les collectivités viennent sonner à la
porte de la des défis mais d'identifier
on voit à peu près lesquels les
collectivités les plus fragiles pour
leur faire connaître le dispositif leur
dire qu'elles peuvent y avoir recours
sur ces 8500 il y a plus d'un millier
1500 demandes d'acompte qui ont son
revenu des collectivités locales et
d'ores et déjà 750 demandes d'acompte
qui ont été acceptées il y a donc déjà
un nombre important d'acompte qui ont
été ordonnés ce que j'ai demandé à mon
équipe et à mon cabinet c'est qu'il y a
un point qui soit fait chaque semaine et
que chaque semaine mon cabinet envoie un
mail à chaque sénateur avec la liste des
communes de son département qui ont pour
lesquels un acompte a été voilà
transparence je pense que c'est
important je considère que dès lors que
c'est en plus un dispositif qui a été
construit de manière transpartisane par
l'ensemble des groupes c'est important
c'est normal que tout le monde puisse
avoir l'information sur sa réalisation
au fil de l'eau chaque semaine ça
demande beaucoup de travail donc désolé
si parfois il y a peut-être un petit
délai dans l'envoi du mail mais en tout
cas j'ai demandé qui est sur reporting
qui soit fait évidemment le fera aussi
pour les députés majorités comme
opposition ensuite il y a le filet de
sécurité 2023 on a retenu dans le cadre
du 49-3 sur la partie 1 du PLF un
amendement parlementaire qui prévoit une
enveloppe d'un milliard 5 et qui prévoit
un dispositif technique de filet de
sécurité qui est un peu différent de
celui de 2022 est-ce que c'est le bon
dispositif ou pas pour le coup je m'en
remets à la sagesse sanatoriale et j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de le dire aux
rapporteur général on attend beaucoup
des travaux que vous conduirez sur le
sujet moi je pense qu'il faut se dire
qu'il y a trois fois plus d'argent que
prévu en 2022 pour le filet de sécurité
collectivité locale en 2023 que notre
objectif et notre intérêt
qui soit dépensé qu'ils aillent aux
bonnes au bon endroit au bon moment et
vous fait confiance pour calibrer le
dispositif que vous jugez le plus
pertinent et le plus efficace pour
soutenir les collectivités en 2023 on
aura là aussi des discussions sur le
sujet en 2000
enfin dans le PLF sur la distinction
investissement financière investissement
productif j'ai pas la réponse là tout de
suite mais je m'engage à demander à mes
équipes de la trouver qu'on puisse vous
communiquer si on dispose des données
madame Lavarde sur la question des EHPAD
en fait pour les EHPAD globalement sur
le secteur de la santé et le
médico-social c'est un peu différent du
budget de l'État puisqu'il y a un PLFSS
rectificatif mais qui est intégré au
PLFSS de l'année suivante c'est la
partie 2 du PLFSS qui est en fait un
PLFSS de fin de gestion mais pour le
PLFSS c'est intégré dans le PLFSS de
l'année suivante et donc on prévoit dans
ce plfs de fin de gestion qui est la
partie 2 du PLFSS 23 une enveloppe de
800 millions d'euros pour faire face au
surcoût de l'inflation dans le secteur
hospitalier dans le secteur
médico-social de même qu'on prévoit 800
millions d'euros en plus pour 2023 c'est
des chiffres qui ont été travaillés
affinés avec les fédérations
hospitalières et médico-sociales alors
j'entends certains qui nous disent
parfois les fédérations hospitalières
faisaient état d'un besoin d'un milliard
100 millions d'euros et vous mettez que
800 millions oui sauf qu'il y avait déjà
en loi de finance loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale initiale pour 2022
autour de 300 millions d'euros qui
étaient provisionnés dans les ARS pour
venir soutenir la trésorerie
d'établissements qui étaient impactés
par la hausse des prix l'énergie donc au
global on s'y retrouve sur le milliard 1
et je remercie leur rapporteur général
de la commission des affaires sociales
du Sénat qui a proposé de rétablir dans
le plfs cette disposition rectificative
puisque à l'Assemblée nationale elle
avait été rejetée par une coalition des
oppositions qui avaient supprimé la
partie rectificative du PLFSS ce qui
veut dire qu'il y avait pas les 800
millions d'euros pour les hôpitaux et
médico-social ce qui est un peu dommage
de la même manière qu'ils avaient rejeté
la prise d'acte des comptes 2021 qui est
la partie 1 du PLFSS merci de l'avoir
établi sur le cast radar oui une
rubrique une rubrique une revue de
gétisation du castradar est étudié ça
doit pas d'aujourd'hui on en entend
parler depuis longtemps notamment pour
le coup au regard de la révision de la
LOLF de 2021 qui appelle à une
nationalisation une rationalisation
pardon des dispositifs extra budgétaires
et donc on travaille là-dessus mais
comme vous l'avez dit au regard du
nombre de parties prenantes ce sujet
nécessite un temps de concertation à
chaque chacun soit infinie assurée de la
pérennité de ses ressources je ne parle
pas que de mon collègue du ministère de
l'intérieur mais aussi évidemment les
collectivités locales et la filtre
s'agissant du financement des transports
mais
j'irai pour ma part je prends pas trop
de risques en le disant puisque c'est
connu je suis plutôt favorable à cette
budgétisation sur ensuite les questions
de Monsieur Billac sur
les accompagnateurs qui seraient des je
ne comprends pas le terme mais chacun
leur a entendu je voulais faire
oppresser oui enfin évidemment
l'objectif c'est que ça soit plus simple
pour l'ensemble des acteurs ce soit les
collectivités locales ou que ce soit les
particuliers et là-dessus mon mes
collègues qui sont chargés du sujet ils
travaillent je pense que mon collègue
Klein aura l'occasion de répondre à des
questions sur ce sujet là mon collègue
Béchu également mais je vous rejoins
totalement dans le fait que on peut
simplifier les démarches notamment pour
ma prime rénov pour les particuliers où
ça reste aussi très compliqué sur un
certain nombre de dossiers sur les la
dotation pour dépenses accidentelles ou
imprévues oui on garde un matelas il y
avait un milliard d'euros qui était
prévu on supprime on annule 500 millions
d'euros mais on garde 500 millions
d'euros parce que par définition en deux
mois il peut se passer des choses dans
notre pays on a vu ces dernières années
à décrire survenir donc pour répondre à
votre question oui nous gardons 500
millions d'euros sur monsieur Segouin
vous avez posé plusieurs questions très
concrètes sur le chèque carburant
travailleur et ça répond aussi à
monsieur sotarel qui avait posé une
question sur le sujet les modalités sont
encore en cours de définition ce que je
peux vous dire sans trop me risquer
c'est qu'on va probablement être très
proche des modalités qu'on avait
retenues pour l'indemnité carburant
travailleur qu'on avait proposé au
Parlement cet été pour mémoire cet été
on avait proposé de sortir de la
ristourne au profit d'un dispositif
ciblé indemnité carburant travailleur
après des discussions avec notamment le
groupe LR de l'Assemblée nationale qui
nous ont permis d'avoir une majorité sur
le PLFR à l'Assemblée nationale nous
avons retiré notre indemnité carburant
travailleur au profit d'une ristourne
augmentée ce qui était demandé par les
LR de l'Assemblée nationale ça nous a
permis d'avoir une majorité sur le texte
raison pour laquelle nous avons une
ristourne de 30 centimes et pas de
dispositif de dispositifs
ciblés moi ce que je proposerais bien si
mais encore une fois c'est si vous le
souhaitez monsieur le Président rénal
sur le rapporteur général c'est que les
services de la dgfipent fassent pour les
sénateurs qu'ils souhaitent une
présentation du dispositif parce que il
y a beaucoup de choses qui avaient été
dites cet été et je pense qu'on n'a pas
été bon pour convaincre que c'était un
dispositif utile et pertinent d'abord on
a entendu que ça allait être une usine à
gaz que ça allait être très compliqué
c'est pas le cas du tout je me suis fait
montrer le dispositif et la page web de
la DG FIP sur le sujet c'est totalement
simple et deux ça a été présenté comme
un nouveau chèque qui irait à des gens
qui travaillent pas alors que les
classes moyennes qui bossent seraient
oubliés pas du tout puisque le premier
critère pour bénéficier de l'indemnité
c'est d'avoir des revenus d'activité
c'est travailler alors ça exclut un
certain nombre de gens notamment les
retraités voilà faut le dire mais si on
dit qu'on faut un dispositif ciblé à un
moment faut qu'il soit ciblé et donc et
donc voilà mais donc pour résumer les
choses et encore une fois ils peuvent
venir vous faire une démonstration et
serait même utile d'avoir votre retour
terrain sur si c'est simple vous rentrez
votre numéro de télédéclarant vous
rentrez votre numéro de carte grise ça
permet de croiser les fichiers et de
voir un si vous avez des revenus
d'activité 2 si vous êtes dans les
plafonds de revenus trois si vous avez
bien une voiture et si c'est le cas le
versement vous est fait dans les 3-5
jours sur votre compte bancaire
directement c'est totalement simple donc
moi je suis très favorable à ce qu'on
réactive ce dispositif qui devait
bénéficier je crois dans la mouture de
cet été à 12 millions de bénéficiaires
évidemment ça tient compte pardon
monsieur sottarel du rural puisque de
mémoire dans le dispositif il y avait
une bonification prévue selon le nombre
de kilomètres que vous déclarez faire
avec votre voiture pour aller travailler
évidemment il y a une part de déclaratif
on mettra jamais un contrôleur de la
DGFiP faudra recruter beaucoup de
fonctionnaires pour revenir sur un débat
qu'on a eu pour vérifier combien de
kilomètres fait chacun avec sa voiture
mais il pourra y avoir des contrôles
aléatoires sur facture des sens pour
contrôler sur sur ensuite la deuxième
question de Monsieur Segoin sur le CPF
vous m'avez demandé quels étaient les
objectifs et qu'elle
et quels sont les indices d'un résultat
sur le sujet l'objectif avec la loi
avenir pro 2018 c'est clairement de
démocratiser l'accès à la formation
professionnelle c'est pour ça que le CPF
a été créé et aujourd'hui le CPF il
permet à tous les actifs de plus de 16
ans d'acquérir des droits à la formation
qui sont désormais libérés libellés non
plus en heure mais en euros à raison de
500 euros par an plafonné à 5000 euros
respectivement 800 et 8000 euros pour
les travailleurs salariés nous on peut
qualifier et les travailleurs en ESAT
donc est-ce que l'objectif d'avoir un
système plus simple pour recourir à de
la formation professionnelle a été tenue
je pense que oui objectivement le
système précédent libellé en heure ou la
plupart des salariés par ailleurs ne
savaient même pas combien d'heures ils
avaient droit il y avait un manque
d'informations c'était objectivement
très compliqué est-ce qu'il faut pour
autant considérer qu'il y a pas besoin
de réguler cette dépense non je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure oui on constate
que cette dépense augmente avec un prix
moyen des formations en 2022 qui est de
1420 euros c'est une augmentation de 17%
par rapport au prix moyen de la
formation formation en 2019 on voit que
certaines formations financées semblent
pour partie déconnecter d'objectifs de
monter en qualification d'où ce que je
mentionnais tout à l'heure sur des
formations un peu anecdotiques mais
voilà des formations dont on se dit pas
totalement sûr que ça doit être financé
donc on doit continuer à avoir ce
travail-là mais au global ça permet
quand même à nos concitoyens de recourir
davantage à la formation professionnelle
et un objectif important sur les PGE oui
il faut évidemment regarder le aussi le
nombre de contentieux et la chute de
trésorerie je vous rejoins totalement
la sinistralité des PGE qui est estimée
ici pour le PLFR de fin de gestion à
court terme
doit être regardé avec une précision un
peu plus grande et on continuera à
regarder en 2023 et ensuite à regarder
évidemment les données ce qu'on constate
cependant c'est que oui il y a une
remontée du nombre de défaillances
d'entreprises avec la reprise de
procédure contentieuse mais que entre
octobre 2021 et septembre
22 dernier référence en date le nombre
de défaillances a atteint 37000 ce qui
reste inférieur de 28% à ce qu'on
constatait en 2019 avant la crise
sanitaire sur une même période pour dire
les choses un peu clairement un il y a
une remontée de la sinistralité c'est
normal puisqu'on est sorti aussi du quoi
qu'il en coûte et donc il y a des
entreprises qui ont parfois certains ont
parlé d'entreprise zombies etc mais qui
ont tenu grâce au quoiqu'il en coûte et
qui quand on sort du quoiqu'il en coûte
ne tiennent plus mais on reste à des
niveaux inférieurs de près d'un tiers
donc plus d'un quart à ce qu'on
connaissait en 2019 avant la crise
sanitaire donc ça reste quand même
positif sur la chute de trésorerie oui
il faut regarder ce point là est-ce
qu'on constate d'ailleurs parce que dans
le débat on entend beaucoup dire les
entreprises gardent des marges très
importantes il y a un point qui est
intéressant à regarder c'est que oui les
marges des entreprises restent
importantes quand vous retirez le
secteur de l'énergie vous avez des
marges qui baissent beaucoup sur les
autres secteurs de l'économie donc faut
regarder plus finement vous avez raison
de le dire et donc faire attention je
reviendrai sur la question des supers
profits aux décisions qu'on prend sur
des entreprises de visiteurs qui ne sont
pas partis du secteur énergétique mais
qui voient une situation qui se tend en
ce moment qui pourrait tendre encore en
2023 d'où la précaution qu'on doit avoir
sur les choix qu'on fait à mon sens sur
la question de Vincent capocanella sur
politique monétaire restrictive versus
politique budgétaire à commodente là
pour le coup Bruno Le Maire est venu
hier en discussion générale de la LPFP
pour porter ce message là vraiment très
fortement il a porté hier vous avez
totalement raison la politique monétaire
se resserre avec la remontée des taux de
la BCE pour lutter contre l'inflation ça
veut dire qu'on est sorti de la
parenthèse de l'argent gratuit on
emprunte plus à ton nul voir ou à taux
zéro et donc ça confirme la nécessité de
passer du quoi qu'il en coûte ou combien
ça coûte et donc d'avoir des dispositifs
ciblés et des mesures d'économie par
rapport à ce que je disais puisque le
poids de la dette est désormais beaucoup
plus sensible à orangehérissement de
notre charge d'intérêt après des années
de baisse ça nécessite donc
effectivement à sérieux budgétaire une
maîtrise des dépenses on a eu des débats
hier nourris sur la LPF sur le rythme de
maîtrise des dépenses dans les 5 années
à venir on considère que le rythme qui
est proposé qui permet de stabiliser la
dette en 26 et de revenir tous les 3% en
27 permet quand même d'avoir cette
maîtrise qui est un message aussi
rassurant pour les agences de notation
les investisseurs ce qui permet de
contenir la remontée de l'auto mais que
avoir une politique plus
importante générale à pas aimé que je
parle de brutal hier mais en tout cas
plus rapide risquerait de casser la
dynamique de croissance économique et
donc il finit de
négative pour les finances publiques
donc mais on continuera à avoir ce débat
dans le cadre de la LPFP j'en profite
pour saluer la responsabilité du Sénat
d'avoir adopté une LPF parce qu'on en a
besoin pour notre crédibilité
internationale et pour les fonds
européens du plan de relance sur les
questions ensuite monsieur Breuillet
j'ai répondu sur les universités j'en ai
parlé sur objectif effectivement
oui évidemment que philosophiquement on
préférait tous mettre l'argent sur les
rénovations thermiques et sur du
structurel plutôt que sur du
conjoncturel et sur du bouclier
tarifaire pour compenser des hausses de
prix de l'électricité je pense qu'on est
tous d'accord là-dessus moi en tant que
budget je regarde pas juste combien en
dépense je regarde si on dépense bien et
là où c'est utile et en l'occurrence ce
qui est utile c'est d'investir pour
aider les Français à mieux isoler leur
logement à changer de véhicule et avoir
ses investissements de long terme
maintenant on a je pense tous un
principe aussi de réalité de pragmatisme
moi je ne sais pas expliquer aux
Français l'an prochain que leurs
factures d'électricité et de gaz va
augmenter de 120% parce qu'on met tout
l'argent sur la rénovation énergétique
alors même en plus vous l'avez dit qu'on
est pas du tout sûr d'être capable de
faire suffisamment de rénovation
énergétique ne serait-ce qu'en termes de
capacité de la filière BTP avec tous les
crédits qui sont mis sur le bouclier
tarifaire donc en fait il faut arriver à
faire les deux
pour arriver à faire les deux c'est à
dire soutenir de manière conjoncturelle
de manière ponctuelle les Français
fassent à la hausse des prix de
l'énergie et elle est de plus en plus
vers un soutien ciblé sur ceux qui ont
le plus besoin c'est ce qu'on fait sur
l'essence ça va être dur je reviendrai
sur l'intervention de Monsieur canvet ça
va être dur mais il faut le faire et
garder des marges de manoeuvre pour
investir dans la rénovation énergétique
dans du plus long terme c'est ce qu'on
fait puisque les crédits dédiés à la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments et
des logements augmentent et sur les la
conversion du parc automobile ça
augmente aussi monsieur sautaré j'ai
répondu sur les collectivités
territoriales et l'indemnité carburant
travailleur madame briquet sur le projet
de loi de règlement
l'examen du PLF pour l'année suivante
donc l'année 2023 en l'occurrence et
conditionné non pas à ce que le projet
de loi de règlement n -2 a été adopté
mais est-ce qu'il est été mis au vote en
l'occurrence il a été mis au vote il a
été rejeté par l'Assemblée nationale en
première lecture donc l'examen et la
constitutionnalité du PLF 2023 n'est pas
remise en cause par le fait que le
projet de loi de règlement n'est pas été
adopté il aurait été remis en cause si
on l'avait pas mis au vote si on l'avait
pas fait discuter par le Parlement
sur les conséquences de ce rejet on
continue à échanger puisque c'est un
fait inédit on en vit un certain nombre
en ce moment dans pas seulement la
Cinquième République la République tout
court je crois que il y avait pas eu de
projet de loi de règlement rejeté depuis
je regarde mon équipe
Monarchie de Juillet c'est ça voilà je
vais pas rentrer dans le voilà mais
depuis longtemps et donc ce qu'on
regarde c'est les conséquences
particulièrement comptables de ce rejet
en gros est-ce que ça a un impact sur la
certification de nos comptes ou pas si
ça en a pas parce qu'il est nécessaire
de remettre un projet de loi de
règlement pour 2021 vu que les
oppositions à l'Assemblée nationale nous
disent on rejettera vos projets de loi
de règlement on n'a pas la majorité
absolue donc à la fin ça laisse peu de
place pour adopter un projet de loi de
règlement
ou pas donc voilà on va voir si c'est
nécessaire en tout cas on déposera un
nouveau texte monsieur Klinger sur les
ETP pour les ARS vous l'avez dit c'est
les ETP qui sont prévus pour faire face
à ce qu'on a annoncé suite à l'affaire
ORPEA c'est-à-dire un plan de contrôle
massif des EHPAD dans notre pays il faut
renforcer pour ça les équipes des ARS
évidemment on continuera à chercher
partout c'est possible des marges
déficience et c'est vrai que leur schéma
d'emploi avait été relevé au moment de
la crise sanitaire donc je pense que
dans les années à venir on devra pouvoir
trouver des marges de ce point de vue là
monsieur je termine par Monsieur Canevet
sur bon la question de la fin de la
ristourne j'ai répondu oui ça va être
dur je ferai pas de parallèle avec les
gilets jaunes je pense que les gilets
jaunes le déclencheur ça a été une
décision du gouvernement de renchérir le
prix du carburant en augmentant la taxe
carbone je pense et je veux pas dire que
c'est facile pour tout le monde mais je
pense que les Français ont intégré que
la hausse des prix du carburant n'est
pas le fait d'un choix du gouvernement
mais il fait d'un rehérissement du coût
du carburant au niveau mondial lié à la
crise que nous connaissons
mais j'assume que nos passions à un
soutien ciblé parce qu'on peut pas se
payer une ristourne à vie il faut aussi
moi je suis là pour avoir un discours de
vérité et vous êtes d'accord avec ça
mais ça fait pas plaisir à entendre pour
nos concitoyens mais on ne peut pas se
payer une ristourne à vie prolonger de
15 jours la restante sur le carburant
comme l'a annoncé la première ministre
c'est 440 millions d'euros pour 15 jours
c'est énorme
on sait aussi par ailleurs que l'argent
public avec la ristourne il finance
aussi en partie le plein de frontaliers
des Belges des Allemands des
Luxembourgeois il y a même des Suisses
qui viennent faire leur plan en France
de départ en week-end aussi de SUV voilà
donc
il faut cibler l'accompagnement je dis
pas que ça va être simple ça va être
difficile mais on assume de le faire
sur la pêche on est très vigilant il y a
un dispositif on sait jamais les
anglicismes mais de top up qui avait été
décidé sur la remise carburant général
pendant le plan de résilience avec des
ouvertures en décret d'avance au
printemps ça devait se terminer fin août
et on l'a encore prolongé de de deux
mois donc il y a au global une remise je
crois de 35 centimes pour la pêche on
sera très vigilant je peux pas vous dire
ce qui sera décidé mon collègue Hervé
bervi évidemment être vigilant sur ce
sujet là on sera vision à protéger nos
pécheurs enfin sur la stabilité des
effectifs publics oui c'est le mandat
qui a été qui m'a été donné par la
première ministre à l'horizon du
quinquennat il y a des créations
importantes l'année prochaine parce que
on traduit les engagements pris dans le
cadre de la campagne présidentielle par
le président notamment de créer 8500
postes de policiers gendarmes
supplémentaires on en met 3000 l'année
prochaine renforcer les postes pour le
ministère de la Justice on en cré un
certain nombre pour l'année prochaine
mystère des armées il y a 3000 créations
prévues dans le prochain quinquennat
avant nouvelle loi de programmation
militaire il pourrait renforcer là aussi
le schéma d'emploi tout ça pour dire que
dire qu'il y a une stabilité des
effectifs publics ne veut pas dire que
les choses seront figées quand on crée
1500 postes dans la justice 8500 postes
au ministère de l'Intérieur au moins
3000 postes pour le ministère de la
Défense ça veut dire que ces postes il
va falloir les trouver ailleurs
redéployer et donc c'est évidemment un
choix qu'on assumera mon ministère Bercy
et régulièrement mis à contribution il
le sera probablement encore mais il y a
un moment ça peut pas être non plus une
ressource inépuisable et on sait qu'il y
a d'autres opérateurs et d'autres
ministères qui pourront être mis à
contribution enfin sur je serais
vraiment très court mais sur la taxation
des super profits pour les raisons que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
ce qui s'est passé depuis quand même le
débat qu'on a eu cet été ou le groupe
Union centriste avait proposé un
amendement sur les super profits c'est
qu'on a ajouté une taxation des super
profits en PLF
cet été je me souviens quand on parlait
du renvoi au travail européen on était
un peu accusé par certains de faire une
manœuvre dilatoire en gros il renvoie au
niveau européen pour enjamber le débat
mais il y aura pas taxation des super
profits depuis il y a eu un accord
européen et il est traduit dans le PLF
et c'est quand même assez massif puisque
il y a une partie de la taxation sur les
super profits décidé au niveau européen
qu'on faisait déjà en France s'appelle
le mécanisme CSPE on récupère la rente
infra marginale des énergéticiens dans
le renouvelable c'est plusieurs dizaines
de milliards d'euros et ensuite ce qu'on
rajoute suite au mécanisme européen
c'est 7 milliards d'euros quand même 7
milliards d'euros en plus en gros on va
capter les rentes indues des
énergéticiens dans le renouvelables et
dans le fossile puisqu'il est aussi
concerné ce qui est proposé qu'est-ce
qui était proposé cet été c'était
d'avoir une taxation qui concerne
l'ensemble des secteurs y compris des
secteurs dont on ne peut pas dire qui
bénéficient de manière induite de
l'inflation pour avoir des bénéfices ou
des profits supplémentaires
nous là-dessus on n'est pas d'accord
effectivement on a un désaccord parce
que on souhaite
[Musique]
on aura ce débat et c'est un beau débat
qui est légitime dans l'hémicycle
merci Monsieur le Ministre
merci pour cette audition
nous allons nous laisser le week-end
quand même pour pas nous voir
très vite
merci beaucoup